so I'm here at one of my least favorite  places the being in the world shopping  at costco Nina loves it here and I hate  it here so I'm usually on the iPad doing  email but it's a big pain because I want  to use my hands to type and so I'm  pushing the cart with my arms d I'm  pushing with my arms and then by the end  of it I have these huge bruises on my  arms and as Nina adds crazy amounts of  stuff to the shopping cart I get bigger  and bigger bruises hard to maneuver and  then Nina came up with an amazing spa  trying to turn hurting the arms Nina  come with an amazing solution the costco  towel trick and it all it is is putting  the towel over the bar so now I put my  arm on the towel and push and it's  amazing and that is the costco towel  trick try it and even better solution is  have shopping carts designed with this  in mind I would go shop at that's